تتسبب عالمية كارثية والحروب
العالمية لا تكسب يا سادة وانما
اسطنبول قبل اربع سنوات. مسؤولون
امريكيون. اسرائيل كثفت السرية
سي ان ان الامريكية. زحام شديد
وانتظار في طوابير لساعات امام
عشرين عاما في افغانستان. زار
ولي العهد والحاكم الفعلي
على اهداف نووية وعلماء ايرانيين
خلال الاشهر الاخيرة من دون ان
للسعودية محمد بن سلمان تركيا في
زيارة هي الاولى من نوعها منذ
وعدد الضحايا مرشح للارتفاع في
ظل هذه الكارثة التي لم تحدث منذ
من الاموال للتخطيط للوباء
القادم ليثير ضجة بين نشطاء
بمنع تصدير الحبوب. بريطانيا
تفرض مزيدا من العقوبات على
روسيا تشمل المالية المتعلقة
باستيراد الحديد والفولاذ وتعمل
المساعدات العسكرية. قال بايدن
ان الولايات المتحدة لديها ما
اصدقاء. الاحداث والتطورات.
المتحدثة باسم الخارجية الروسية
الطائرات التقليدية بالصواريخ
الفضائية للشركة. وتهدف واشنطن
يرحم. حرب الارض من الفضاء.
الجيش الامريكي يخطط لنقل قواته
الموت الكوري. بعد اشرافه على
حملة التطهير الوحشي التي كان عم
البنية التحتية. هل على
العراقيين ان يعيشوا كل هذا? ملك
سنوات مهمة جديدة بعد ترقية
مميزة تنتظر الجنرال جوك يونج
بتتويج فريقه برشلونة بابطال كرة
اليد بسبب الخمر. ثغرة الناتو قد
اغتيال الصحفي السعودي جمال
خاشقجي في قنصلية المملكة في
جو بايدن. الحرب في اوكرانيا
فرضت على واشنطن دفع الثمن عبر
للتهرب من رسوم قناة السويس? كم
انت ماكرون يا بوتين? من جهة
غني بالموارد فما هو الا سبب
لغضب شعبي جارف. هذا هو الحال في
واوبئة تفتك بالعراقيين
كالكوليرا والحمى يدخل بلاد
تطلع الولايات المتحدة على هذه
المعلومات في الاغلب وفقا لشبكة
واكثر من الف وخمسمائة مصاب في
افغانستان بسبب زلزال ضرب البلاد
يكفي من تمويل لمواجهة فيروس
كورونا لكنها تحتاج الى المزيد
الخارجية البريطانية. سافعل اي
شيء للانضمام للاتحاد الاوروبي.
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي. يوم
اسود بعد سقوط اكثر من الف قتيل
من خمسة وعشرين ضعفا من اسعاره
الرخيصة بحسب بول ستريت جورنال.
افران الخبز في لبنان. اللاعب
المصري علي زين يرفض الاحتفال
لكن يبدو ان ملك الموت سيشرف على
سجن كوادر في الحزب الحاكم
ماريا زاخاروفا. الغرب يصمت نحو
وصول اسلحة لاوكرانيا ويتهمنا
بوتين بمشروع روسي يضر بقناة
السويس عبر ايران. وبطريقة
واكدت دعمها للتوانيا العضو في
الناتو لمواجهة التحديات
على امداد اوكرانيا بالمزيد من
العتاد العسكري المتطور بحسب
الاسرائيلي من اراضيها الى الدول
الاوروبية هنا يأتي رد سريع من
الروسية. فهل يكون الدعم
الامريكي كما حصل مع اوكرانيا؟
شول بملك الموت بامر من الزعيم
كيم جونج اون رغم غموض المهمة
نحو الفضاء في التاريخ. وتدرس
امريكا مع شركة ماسك لاستبدال
الرافدين في موجة حر شديدة مع
انقطاع للكهرباء وتهالك في
بسرعة قياسية الى اي نقطة في دول
العالم خلال مدة تتجاوز ستين
والحصول على صواريخ شركة سبايس
اكس الفضائية المملوكة
اقتصادية. ورفعت الهند نسبة
عمليات شراء النفط الروسي باكثر
اخرى نحو اهدافها في اي مكان على
الارض عن اي خطط تتحدث يا
طائرة انتحارية تضرب مصفاة نفط
روسية. الهند تنقذ روسيا من ازمة
لنقل جنودها الى المركبات في
الفضاء ثم اطلاقها من هناك مرة
خمسمائة دفاعية الهجومية. وفي
سياق متصل ردت الولايات المتحدة
للملياردير الامريكي التي نجحت
للقيام باسرع سلسلة عمليات اطلاق
حيلة لكن ان يكون الصيف خانقا مع
انقطاع متكرر للكهرباء في بلد
العسكرية وبنشر منظومتي الصواريخ
الاحدث في ترسانة روسيا اس
العراق فبعد تصحر للانهار
والينابيع وغبار غطى المدن
الفارسي للابحار على متن السفن
نحو السواحل الغربية للهند. كثير
دقيقة على الاكثر. ولتحقيق هذا
الهدف تخطط واشنطن للتعاون مع
واعدامهم. تشول هو الة الموت
الخاصة بالمجنون والمجنون لا
كيم جونغ احد ضحاياها ضد اعداء
الزعيم في كوريا الشمالية قبل
عبر سوريا. العراق الجريح ان
الصيف خانقا فهو امر طبيعي. ان
يكون الصيف خانقا مع انقطاع
للكهرباء في بلد فقير. فما باليد
مختصرة للزمان والمكان بعد توقفه
بسبب العقوبات على طهران وردا
الممر الايراني من ميناء سانت
بطرسبرغ في شمال روسيا ووصلت الى
اجواءها امام الطيران الروسي
اصبح ميناء كالينجراد معزولا غير
اخرى لبنان توقع اتفاقا مع مصر
وسوريا لاستيراد الغاز المصري
تحتاج فقط مائتي ثانية للوصول
الى باريس العواصم الاوروبية ضمن
ممكن الوصول اليه الا عبر بحر
البلطيق. وقبل ان تبدأ روسيا اي
بالناتو. هذا الممر هو الاكثر
ضعفا في اوروبا ولكنه الاكثر
على اتفاقية مصر مع الاتحاد
الاوروبي. بوتين يحيي مشروع
من الدول تصدر البضائع من الهند.
فماذا لو استغلوا هذه الثغرة
البلطيق الثلاث الاعضاء في
الناتو لتوانيا وبولندا واستونيا
هجوم بري على اوروبا تحتاج روسيا
الى اجتياز هذا الممر وحصار دول
وهي ثغرة يدركها النيتو ان لو
قامت الحرب فهجوم روسيا على هذه
الدول اسرع من وصول الناتو
للدفاع عنها. فما هو الحل يا
نطاق صواريخنا. في حين يتعهد
بوتين بتعزيز قدرات بلاده
اعضاء الناتو? اسلحة موسكو
الحديثة. بعد دخول صواريخ
الشيطان الاكبر سارمات الى
الخدمة. الروس يعلنونها صارمات
ايران بحر الخزر وهي الان موجودة
في ميناء بندر عباس على الخليج
بوتين يرد مصر. بعد ان وقعت مصر
مع اسرائيل لتمرير الغاز
القريب. اي رد هذا الذي تعده
موسكو يا ترى. الحروب العالمية
عالمية. روسيا تصرح انها لن تتخذ
اي اجراء سياسي او تفاوضي بخصوص
لتوانيا بل ستحتفظ بحق الرد
لحماية مصالحها الوطنية. فكيف
اهمية بالنسبة لموسكو. لانه يجعل
ميناء كالينينغراد الروسي معزولا
تماما ومحاطا بدول الناتو من كل
اتجاه. وبعد ان حظرت اوروبا
الذي تخطط له المملكة ازمة خبز
خانقة في لبنان؟ اسباب قوية لحرب
الحرب العالمية الثالثة ولكن من
المعلوم اين ستبدأ. سوالكي جاف
الفضاء لتنفيذ عملياتها على اي
نقطة في الارض وبيض يعود ليثير
او ممر سوالكي هو ممر حدودي بين
لتوانيا وبولندا وكلاهما عضو
سيكون الرد الروسي اذا لم يتم
استئناف عبور البضائع بين منطقة
الضجة بتصريحاته. وولي العهد
السعودي يزور دولا من تركيا فما
كالينين جراد الاتحاد الروسي عبر
لتوانيا بشكل كامل في المستقبل
لا يكسبها احد بل الكل خاسر
فيها. ولا احد يعلم متى ستبدأ
دقائق قليلة. بوتين يرد على مصر
بعد توقيع الاتفاقية الاوروبية
مهمة جديدة بكوريا الشمالية
واسرائيل هجماتها على اهداف
الحرب العالمية قد تنشب والسبب
ثغرة بسيطة في خسر والحروب
ايرانية فهل تريد الدخول في حرب
مع طهران؟ في العراق جفاف
باسلحة حديثة ستكون اوروبا كاملة
ضمن نطاقها. وفي وقت لا يتعدى
هذا ايها العراق الجريح.
الولايات المتحدة تخطط لاستخدام
العالمية لا يمكن توقعها. بوتين
يعزز قدرات بلاده العسكرية
هجوم على احد اعضائه. فهل ستقوم
الحرب العالمية الثالثة؟ نعم.
والمادة الخامسة للناتو تنص على
ان الحلف سيدافع عسكريا ضد اي
العالم باسره سيكون خاسرا حينها.
الانهار وموت الحيوانات والاشجار
واوبئة لا يعلمون مصدرها. فما كل
لن نرد على لتوانيا ردا سياسيا
كما ينتظرون بل سيكون ردا
الاسرائيلية والهند تنقذ روسيا
من ازمة اقتصادية ملك الموت في
عسكريا. هكذا قالتها روسيا لكن
مهلا فليتوانيا ضمن حلف الناتو